В ефірі «heute journal» з
Ґундулою Ґаузе та Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Доброго вечора усім глядачам,
сьогодні ми почнемо
з досить важливих новин.
Погляньмо на ситуацію в окупованому
Південному Cході України,
ці регіони були захоплені Росією під час війни
після тривалих, жорстоких боїв.
Є місця, про які ми мало знали ще кілька тижнів тому,
однак про них постійно говорять в новинах:
це Маріуполь,
Лисичанськ, Сєвєродонецьк.
Знімальна група ZDF з
репортером Вінандом Верніке
побувала там і взяла інтерв'ю
у місцевих жителів.
Варто зважати на дві важливі речі:
ситуація в регіоні, як і раніше,
досить нестабільна.
За повідомленнями британської розвідки,
Росія там розбудовує свої позиції
і водночас знову посилює
ракетні та артилерійські удари
по території України.
Саме з цієї причини
наша телевізійна група
була обмежена в переміщенні
і дозволялось знімати
лише під пильним наглядом
російських військових.
Такі поїздки знімальної групи
називають «вбудованими».
З одного боку, ми перебуваємо
поблизу району бойових дій,
і нас охороняють
озброєні російські солдати.
З іншого боку, за кожним нашим кроком
уважно стежать
представники Міністерства оборони з Москви.
Про це здогадуються
і мешканці Сєвєродонецька,
які живуть в руїнах, і, звичайно ж,
ретельно підбирають слова.
Чому я маю йти звідси?
Це моє місто.
Я тут народилась і живу.
Україна була моєю батьківщиною.
Тут була Україна. Але
я російськомовна людина.
Я розмовляю російською.
Розбиті дороги, зруйновані мости,
місця, непридатні для проживання.
Це подорож до територій,
де тижнями тривали бої
між Росією та Україною.
Лисичанськ лежить посеред руїн,
в місті немає струму, води та їжі.
«Ми разом» - написано на
упаковках з гуманітарною допомогою.
Є думка, що майбутнє
Донбасу - в складі Росії.
Мені байдуже, хто тут буде,
Путін чи Зеленський.
Головне, аби цей жах скінчився і настав мир.
Однак не всі вірять у швидке настання миру,
а думки про майбутнє викликають страх,
адже Україна хоче повернути території
і оголосила контрнаступ.
Це означає, що треба знову
готуватися до запеклих боїв.
Тут представлена зброя,
яку використовувала українська армія.
Ці системи, захоплені росіянами,
були завезені із Заходу.
Це своєрідний трофей
і послання до НАТО,
що підтримка, яку організація надсилає Україні,
не допоможе.
Блакитне небо і жовта пшениця -
це національні кольори України.
Але тут жнива відбуваються
під російським прапором.
Вже не перший тиждень світ тривожить запитання,
чи не стане голод зброєю війни,
адже обсяги експорту зерна спеціально знижені.
Росія це заперечує.
Тут, наприклад, сподіваються на хороший врожай.
На наступний день після
збору врожаю ми продаємо його в Росію.
Вони ж далі продають його Туреччині та Сирії.
Але куди ще продають наше зерно,
я не знаю точно.
Російський гімн звучить в будівлі
державної адміністрації Мелітополя.
Російські паспорти видаються
за прискореною процедурою.
Таке розпорядження президента Путіна.
Російський паспорт зараз дуже важливий.
Треба паспорт, щоб отримувати пенсію,
а як мені жити?
Я одна, без чоловіка, а син живе в Німеччині.
Восени має відбутись референдум
із приєднання регіону до Росії.
Безсумнівно, це вплине
на політичну та воєнну ситуацію.
Жителям все ще загрожуватиме небезпека.
Вінанд Верніке знову в Москві.
Доброго вечора, Вінанде.
Ви здійснили так звану «вбудовану» поїздку
для зйомки під охороною російської армї.
З якою метою Росія
дозволяє і організовує такі поїздки?
Це звичайний піар.
PR, як це часто люблять характеризувати.
Йдеться про те, що росіяни помічають,
що позиція України значно сильніша,
про Україну говорять на міжнародному рівні.
Тому вони прагнуть цьому протидіяти.
Росія розповсюджує фейкові новини,
це засіб пропаганди.
Я був два рази в Сирії в супроводі російських військ.
Тобто звітність буде контролюватися,
і це означає відсутність свободи.
Однак це також можливість отримати
уявлення про регіон,
побачити, як сильно постраждали міста.
Фактично Росія бажає
висвітлювати ці події в своїх ЗМІ.
Однак ми можемо взяти щось і для своїх медіа,
і це важливий факт.
Як почувається репортер в супроводі армії,
як взагалі реагують на це люди?
Так, насправді досить незвично,
коли ти постійно в супроводі осіб,
які не спускають з тебе очей,
де б ти не був і що б не робив.
Журналісти мають працювати
зовсім не так.
Люди, які там проживають і потрапляють в такі умови,
одразу помічають увагу до журналіста,
розуміють, що мають справу
із західними ЗМІ.
Звісно ж, присутні багато офіційних представників,
тому люди максимально стримані.
Однак все ж можна побачити дійсність.
Може звучати дивно, однак
це все ж спосіб розглянути ситуацію.
Це був Вінанд Верніке з Москви,
дякую за репортаж.
Тепер - до новин Німеччини.
Наскільки гарячою, часом аж занадто,
видається дискусія довкола енергетичної
кризи та її наслідків,
добре проглядається в інтерв'ю,
яке днями дав керівник
Федерального мережевого агентства.
У четвер він попередив про
потрійне зростання рахунку за газ,
сьогодні він застерігає від паніки,
адже наявні ознаки того,
що ціни далі не збільшуватимуться.
Німеччина та інфляція -
це особливі стосунки
десь між здоровим побоюванням,
необхідними контрзаходами та усе ближчою
панікою. Андреас Вайзе далі.
Це одна з найприємніших зустрічей
для прем'єр-міністра Газелоффа.
Винне братство регіону Заале-Унструт
нагороджує найкращі напої,
створені на Півдні Саксонії-Ангальт.
Однак для політики зараз не час на дозвілля.
Ми живемо вже в іншому світі,
і, напевно, ці зміни довготривалі.
Тому протягом наступних тижнів
ми мусимо протистояти концепції,
що призведе не лише до того,
що один талон, тобто квиток на пальне за дев'ять євро,
доведеться розтягувати на 12 тижнів,
це не вирішить проблему.
Пропозицій достатньо.
Прем'єр-міністр Баварії Зедер
наполягає на запровадженні річних квитків
по 365 євро та знижок на автозаправку до зими.
Співголова SPD Ескен в літньому
інтерв'ю ZDF пропонує дещо,
що навряд чи сподобається
партнерам у «світлофорній» коаліції з FDP.
Якщо бюджет на наступний рік
дійсно буде ухвалено
у вересні і в грудні,
тоді в першому, другому і третьому читанні
ми побачимо,
чи ми матимемо змогу
виключити боргове гальмо.
Адже ми застрягли в кризі
і навіть не можемо передбачити наслідки інших криз.
Я вважаю, що потрібно зупинити боргове гальмо.
Особливо високі ціни на енергоносії
позначаться на людях
з низьким доходом, адже і під час пандемії
ця частина населення постраждала найбільше.
Вони можуть зазнати дедалі серйозніших труднощів,
адже якщо в часи пандемії було так,
що офісні працівники з хорошим заробітком
могли безпечно працювати з дому,
то багато людей з галузі громадського харчування
втратили роботу, за яку їм і до того платили копійки.
Інфляція.
Здається, це слово в Німеччині
викликає очевидні побоювання.
Для цього є й історичні підстави,
оскільки мільярдні купюри
1923 року і валютна реформа у 1948 році
глибоко врізались в колективну пам'ять.
Я думаю, що
досвід гіперінфляції у 1923 році,
а потім, звичайно,
валютна реформа у 1948 році
перейшли в культурну пам'ять німців,
адже стабільність валюти
тісно пов'язана
з політичною стабільністю.
Політичної стабільності достатньо,
однак дедалі більше людей
в країні забувають про політику.
Ми просто мусимо зараз побачити, що те,
що було економічним успіхом
Німецької Демократичної Республіки,
те, про що ми говорили,
має бути на устах
і надалі залишатися позитивним явищем.
Політики і суспільство -
усі мають швидко знайти способи боротьби з інфляцією,
адже, очевидно, найближчим часом
її рівень не падатиме.
BASF - це найбільший у світі хімічний концерн.
Для функціонування компанії потрібна
неймовірна кількість енергії,
і лише вона споживає майже 4%
від усього газу Німеччини.
З нами в студії Зініша Горват,
голова Виробничої ради BASF.
Добрий вечір.
Якщо BASF більше не отримуватиме
газ із Росії, як це вплине на всіх нас?
Насамперед ми, звісно, не хотіли б, щоб так сталося.
Для нас, як і для всіх у Німеччині,
це величезне випробування.
Хімічна промисловість - це не самоціль.
Це джерело матеріалів,
які ми застосовуємо в усіх сферах життя:
сільське господарство, харчова промисловість,
автомобілебудування тощо.
Так, BASF виробляє матеріали для фармацевтичної
промисловості, товари якої ми бачимо в аптеках,
які нам потрібні в повсякденні, коли ми хворіємо.
І за найгіршим сценарієм, у разі відмови
від російського газу, ми все це втратимо?
У коротко- й середньостроковій перспективі - безумовно.
Ланцюги постачання зазвичай короткі,
вони є частиною цієї системи,
тому такі наслідки були б логічними.
Як BASF готується до такого сценарію,
чи маєте Ви запасний план?
Загалом ми готуємося
до трансформації в середньо-
й довгостроковій перспективі.
Така перспектива поставала перед нами ще до ситуації
з Росією, хоча зараз, звісно, потрібно діяти швидше.
Окрім цього, зараз ми бачимо проблеми,
які виникнуть незабаром,
вони пов'язані з необхідністю
обмежити споживання газу.
Ми розглядаємо можливість скорочення споживання
до 67%, з такими змінами ми зможемо впоратися.
Ми дамо собі раду, скоротивши споживання і до 50%,
але якщо газу буде зовсім мало, ситуація погіршиться.
Розгляньмо ситуацію, коли постачання газу з Росії
скоротиться більш як на 50%.
Як саме може погіршитися ситуація?
Що це означатиме для працівників?
Якщо роботу центру у Людвіґсгафені доведеться
припинити через дефіцит газу,
ми муситимемо чекати на додаткові ресурси.
Я вже наголошував на тому,
що наше виробництво є частиною системи.
Хімічна промисловість - це не самоціль.
Ми працюємо для людей і для їхнього майбутнього.
Тож все залежить і від того,
скільки газу ми отримаємо в майбутньому,
адже Росія - не єдиний потенційний постачальник газу.
Це питання, які постануть перед нами незабаром.
Які зараз настрої панують серед працівників?
Чи не мають вони надії на те,
що Путін не перейде цю межу?
З одного боку ще з лютого
над нами висить цей дамоклів меч.
З іншого - наше виробництво дуже успішне,
ми працюємо на повну потужність,
адже на нашу продукцію є великий попит.
Врешті-решт працівники щодня приходять на роботу
й належно виконують свої обов'язки.
Команда завжди працює дуже згуртовано.
Але, звісно, ніхто не знає,
що буде завтра.
У цьому й полягає взаємодія
Виробничої ради й підприємства:
повідомляти команді про поточну ситуацію.
У Німеччині триває дискусія щодо того,
хто буде в пріоритеті в умовах дефіциту газу.
Зараз стверджують, що дефіцит вплине насамперед
на промисловість, споживачі ж не постраждають.
Що думають працівники BASF, які тепер змушені
хвилюватися про те, як не втратити роботу?
Чи не надають вони перевагу роботі
над теплою домівкою?
Я не люблю крайнощі,
як-от мерзнути заради роботи.
Усе це - одна система.
Щоб зрештою мати змогу купити продукти, ліки, авто,
потрібно все ж жити в теплій квартирі.
Але ми мусимо робити кілька справ одночасно,
розробляти видобування зрідженого газу,
співпрацювати з Європою,
зокрема Бельгією, Францією й Нідерландами.
Потрібно використовувати весь потенціал
терміналів для зрідженого газу.
У Європі має панувати взаємопідтримка.
Деякі плани поки залишаються на папері,
їх ще необхідно втілити.
Наприклад, розподіл ресурсу з терміналів для
зрідженого газу між європейськими державами.
Це нагальні питання.
Потрібно виконати багато окремих кроків.
Також на цьому етапі необхідно залучити вугілля,
відмовитися від електростанцій,
які використовують газ, накопичити газ,
і натомість залучити до виробництва енергії
вугільні електростанції.
Мешканці можуть вирішити померзнути,
знизити температуру вдома на 1°С
і допомогти економіці, але все ж замерзнути.
У цьому контексті кожен може зробити свій внесок,
і хімічна промисловість - не виняток.
З нами був Зініша Горват, голова Виробничої ради
компанії BASF, щиро дякую за розмову.
А зараз - огляд новин від моєї колеги Ґундули.
На Півночі Греції розбився український вантажний літак,
який перевозив понад 11 тонн боєприпасів.
Усі вісім членів екіпажу загинули.
Напередодні катастрофи пілот повідомив
про проблеми з двигуном
та не зміг здійснити аварійну посадку.
Літак «Антонов» віз боєприпаси
сербського оборонного підприємства
у Банґладеш.
Ці дані офіційно підтверджено.
На місці катастрофи рятувальним роботам
перешкоджали постійні вибухи
і їдкий дим.
Президент України Зеленський
відсторонив дві головні фігури
у системі правоохоронних органів країни:
голову Служби безпеки України
та Генеральну прокурорку.
Відповідні укази щойно оприлюднили
на офіційному вебсайті президента.
Причину звільнень не повідомляли.
Партія AfD в парламенті землі Баден-Вюртемберґ
обрала нових очільників:
наступниками Аліс Вайдель стали
депутат Бундестагу Фронмаєр
і депутат земельного парламенту Зенце.
Вони прагнуть об'єднати
земельне представництво партії,
яке розділене на два табори:
помірних консерваторів і радикальних націоналістів.
На з'їзд партії гострої критики зазнало
спостереження за AfD у Баден-Вюртемберзі
Державним відомством з охорони конституції.
Президент Франції Макрон закликав зберігати пильність
щодо проявів антисемітизму.
З нагоди 80-річчя наймасштабніших
масових арештів євреїв у Франції
у період Другої світової війни
прем'єр-міністерка Франції Борн
вшанувала пам'ять жертв.
1942 року французька поліція
за наказом окупаційної влади нацистської Німеччини
заарештувала 13 тис. євреїв
і депортувала їх до німецьких таборів смерті.
Упродовж багатьох десятиліть ці події
були у Франції темою-табу.
Тривають масштабні лісові пожежі
в багатьох регіонах Південної Європи.
Подекуди пожежним службам ледве вдається
зупинити вогонь.
У Франції лише на південь від Бордо полум'я знищило
понад 10 тис. га лісу.
Через сильні вітри пожежі щоразу посилюються.
Повідомляють, що жахлива спека,
яка сприяє виникненню пожеж,
найближчими днями пошириться на північ
і дійде до Німеччини й Великобританії.
Історичні зміни -
еволюція сприйняття цього поняття нагадує інфляцію.
Що детальніше аналізувати це явище,
то раптом менш зрозумілим і героїчним воно здається.
Наприклад, розгляньмо видобування газу
біля берегів Німеччини у Північному морі.
Ще минулої осені земельний уряд
Нижньої Саксонії відкинув цю пропозицію
з огляду на небезпеку для флори й фауни
Національного парку Ватового моря.
Зараз усе змінилося.
Той самий земельний уряд Нижньої Саксонії
тепер пропонує видобувати газ у Північному морі
з огляду на складку ситуацію з постачанням енергоносія.
Історичні зміни.
Лише мешканці островів,
як-от Боркуму, не підтримують їх.
Ба більше, вони подають
позов до суду проти цих планів.
Петер Кунц бачив все на власні очі.
Ми підлітаємо до нідерландської
бурової платформи для видобування газу,
яка розташована за 30 км від
німецького узбережжя Північного моря.
Нідерландці - експерти з розробки
невеликих прибережних газових родовищ.
Керівник вважає цю платформу
порятунком в умовах енергетичної кризи.
Уряд Нідерландів очікує,
що локальне видобування газу в обсязі 1 млрд тонн
матиме на 0,5 млн тонн менше викидів CO2,
ніж імпорт зрідженого газу.
Електрифікація процесу видобування
заощадить ще 1 млн.
Стосується це і викопних джерел енергії,
навколишнього середовища та захисту клімату.
Буріння у відкритому морі
не має бути «брудною» справою -
ось що потрібно донести.
7 км звідси нідерландська компанія One-Dyas
планує створити голландсько-німецьку платформу.
А з 2024 року - видобувати для Німеччини
1 ﻿млрд тонн газу на рік.
Стабільний 1% загальнонаціонального
річного споживання.
Німеччина ще має 42 км³ власних запасів
природного газу,
більша частина якого зберігається
в ґрунтах Нижньої Саксонії.
Північноморський газ, знайдений
за допомогою таких бурових платформ,
допоможе країні швидше
здобути енергетичну незалежність.
Серце операції - пункт управління
свердловими головками.
Вони сягають глибини 4,5 км,
так пояснює данський працівник, керуючи свердлом.
За допомогою поперечного свердла голландці хочуть
відводити запаси газу під Ватовим морем.
З Німеччини сюди прибули
представник нижньосаксонського гірничого управління,
аби дати згоду на експлуатацію з боку Німеччини,
та постачальник енергії з міста Ольденбург,
котрий є партнером у транскордонному
спільному підприємстві.
Перед нами постала унікальна можливість:
постачати енергією для дослідження
з однієї з наших вітроелектростанцій
і одночасно забезпечити
надійне газопостачання для наших клієнтів.
Можливо, саме тут біля узбережжя
заховано 60 млрд км³ газу,
які допоможуть розв'язати головоломку,
яку загадав Путін.
Сусідній острів відпочинку Боркум б'є на сполох:
жодна експлуатаційна вежа не має блокувати огляд.
Через це місцеві жителі подали позов до суду на
сусідній острів Юст
і німецьку організацію із захисту довкілля
та прав споживачів в Нідерландах.
Видобуток природного газу загалом -
це «брудна» справа,
де використовується низка токсичних хімікатів,
які мають бути під сталим наглядом.
Якщо трапиться аварія - викиди підуть у море.
Окрім цього, є ще й газоподібні викиди, що
утворюються у результаті згоряння.
Загалом процес виробництва
важко підтримувати «чистим».
А якщо розглядати довгострокову перспективу,
то панує ризик
сейсмічних розломів чи зменшення
основи острова.
Міський голова протистоїть енергетичним змінам,
які загрозою нависають над островом.
Минулого року парламент Нижньої Саксонії відхилив
проєкт будівництва на острові Боркум,
проте зараз це рішення скасовано.
Німеччина постачає газ, аби його ж і отримувати,
жертвуючи цією райською місциною
у Ватовому морі - об'єктом Світової спадщини.
А тепер огляньмо спортивні новини з
Ґундулою Ґаузе.
Чемпіонат світу з легкої атлетики
в американському штаті Орегон:
участь взяли найшвидші та найвитриваліші бігуни.
Фінальний забіг на 100 м:
«золото», «срібло» та «бронзу» здобуває США.
Переможцем став Фред Керлі з результатом 9,86 с.
Маратонці змагалися довше,
але таки здобули подвійну перемогу для Ефіопії:
Тамірат Тола став чемпіоном світу.
Щоб здолати 42 км, йому знадобилося
2 год, 5 хв і 36 сек.
Майже цілий день велосипедисти
боролися за перемогу на 15-му етапі
«Тур де Франс».
Першим прийшов бельгієць Яспер Філіпсен.
Це його перша проміжна перемога у змаганні.
Він подолав 200 км за температури близько 40°.
Усе вирішив фінішний спринт:
переміг 24-річний Філіпсен,
обігнавши свого земляка Ваута ван Арта.
За ними позаду у жовтій футболці -
Йонас Вінгегор - велосипедист з Данії
та берлінець Сімон Ґешке в
гірській футболці.
«Я б дуже хотів побувати з
вами на морі в Північній Німеччині,
щоб дозволити різкому пориву вітру
та незначній північнонімецькій грубості
снувати навколо голови».
Ці слова належать не мені, а Йоганнесу Брамсу.
І це не про нахабство,
це про щиру тугу за
батьківщиною на узбережжі,
яка не минула у композитора навіть у Відні.
Як добре та доречно, що творчість Йоганнеса Брамса -
лейтмотив музичного фестивалю
у Шлезвіг-Гольштайні, який триває до кінця серпня.
І як цікаво побачити, що ж там відбувається,
коли музиканти зовсім різних музичних стилів,
як-от гра на саксофоні, цимбалах чи
навіть електроджаз, створюють щось унікальне.
Брамс не знає меж. Детальніше - Зогад Халді.
Електронні біти,
базовий джем і техно звук.
Гурт Jazzrausch грає Брамса,
поєднуючи класику з біг-бендом,
джазом та електро.
Брамс - запальний, Брамс - інакший.
* музика *
Звичайно, що це теж виклик.
Я і уявити не міг, що за такий короткий час
на сцені, можливо створити таку музику.
Я тільки зараз розумію,
наскільки це було круто.
* Музика *
Зокрема, тут виконують композиції, створені
за епохи пізнього романтизму -
Йоганнесом Брамсом понад 180 років тому.
24 народні пісні на альпійський лад.
Виконує тірольський гурт Franui.
* Музика *
Про Брамса розповідають, що він
вивчав угорські мотиви у Відні.
Навчили його повії у борделі і таке інше.
Хоча така версія не користується популярністю.
Але для нашої музичної
інтерпретації вона якраз пасує.
Як і у музиці: місцями не все так красиво,
місцями непристойно, якщо забажаєте.
Музичний фестиваль у Шлезвіг-Гольштайні
розкриває творчість північнонімецького композитора
з різних перспектив
під час низки концертів.
У нас понад 200 концертів,
з яких ми присвячуємо майже половину
творчості Брамса або ж покликаємося
на його твори під час виступів у понад
100 різноманітних місцях.
Звичайно, виконуємо також Брамса в оригіналі.
* Музика *
Грає Ігор Левіт - зірковий піаніст
і прихильник творчості Брамса.
* Музика *
Надзвичайне захоплення.
Я люблю грати його музику усім серцем,
особливо другий фортепіанний концерт.
Це наповнює мене та надихає.
Звільняє та робить дуже щасливим.
Романтизм поєднується з технологічністю.
Неймовірне задоволення від звучання.
Нагадуємо, що музичний фестиваль
у Шлезвіг-Гольштайні триває аж до кінця серпня.
* Музика *
Які новини чекають на нас уже наступного тижня:
короткий огляд подій від
Лаури Барнік в ефірі «heute journal».
У понеділок у Берліні відбудуться переговори
канцлера Німеччини Шольца
та президента Єгипту Ас-Сісі.
Привід для зустрічі - 13ий
«Петерсберзький кліматичний діалог»,
необхідний для підготовки кліматичного саміту ООН,
котрий відбудеться восени у місті Шарм-еш-Шейх.
Цьогоріч Німеччина та Єгипет прийматимуть
гостей з інших країн.
Після відвідин Олафа Шольца
Ас-Сісі попрямує з візитом до федерального президента
у палаці Бельв'ю.
У середу комісія ЄС у Брюсселі
презентує свій проєкт кризового плану:
як підготуватися до можливої нестачі газу
восени або взимку.
Щоб заощадити, наприклад,
ітиметься про зменшення опалення
громадських будівель та офісів.
Комісія ЄС наголошує, що найвища
позначка термометра
не має перевищувати 19°С.
Затамувавши подих, чекаємо четверга:
завершення робіт з технічного обслуговування
газогону «Північний потік-1».
Ще у червні Росія різко зменшила
поставки газу через ремонтні роботи.
Європа глибоко стурбована,
що Росія не відновить потік газу
після поточних робіт з технічного обслуговування труб
з політичних причин.
А зараз - про погоду. Цього липневого тижня
очікується пекельна спека.
Завтра позначка термометра коливатиметься
від 27 до 36°С.
Багато сонячних променів на півдні країни.
На півночі - подекуди хмарно,
а на північному сході
небо застелять густі хмари.
На узбережжях -
свіжий вітер і температура повітря 23-27°С.
У вівторок температура
на заході підніметься аж до 40°С.
На всій території Німеччини
температура перевищить 30°С.
У середу - місцями грози,
найтепліше буде на сході.
Це був недільний випуск новин з «heute journal».
Дякуємо, що були з нами.
Нагадуємо про новини «heute Xpress»
з Крістофером Верманом о 00:30 год.
Ми прощаємося до завтра.
І від усієї команди: гарного вечора!